welcome to the show everybody I hope you
had a wonderful weekend I know that mine
was okay a bit a little bit a little bit
sleep-deprived really um you know we
have an infant in the house
who wakes up like three times a night as
infants are prone to do but then we also
have a three-year-old who has recently
decided to get into this lovely phase
where he also gets up like three times a
night and then finally will wake up at 4
a.m. and and he's ready to start the day
at 4 a.m. he doesn't go back to bed
after 4 a.m. so it's been it's been you
know it's it's our kids are trying to
kill us basically they're trying to this
is my distress call to the world they're
trying to kill us because sleep is a
human need you can't survive without it
what they're doing is a violation of the
Geneva Convention I mean if you were the
warden of a prison and you woke your
inmates up 6 times a night you would be
charged with human rights violations yet
this is what our kids are doing to us
and I tried to explain this to my
three-year-old last night at 4 a.m. but
he wasn't getting it he just doesn't
give a damn about the Constitution
honestly he's a he's a total Lib I blame
his parents honestly anyway so Ricky
Gervais is at the Golden Gloves you know
he actually made a Hollywood awards
ceremony watchable for at least 7
minutes which which is an enormous
achievement it seems like an
impossibility right it seems like making
an award show watchable it's like if an
IRS agent made and made an audit
enjoyable or if your dentist made it fun
to get a root canal it just seems like
it's not possible but Gervaise pulled it
off mainly by ruthlessly mocking the
hollywood degenerates and attendance
you've probably seen his opening
monologue already but if you haven't if
you haven't seen it
let's I'll play for you now this is
probably my favorite part of his opening
monologue
we were going to do an in memoriam this
year but when I saw the list of people
that had died it wasn't diverse enough
they just no it was mostly white people
and I thought now not on my watch
maybe next year let's let's see what
happened no one cares about movies
anymore no one goes to the cinema no one
really what is network TV
everyone's watching Netflix this show
should just be me coming out going well
done Netflix you win everything good
night but no no we got a drag out for
three hours you could binge watch the
entire first season of afterlife instead
of watching this show that that's a show
about a man who wants to kill himself
because his wife dies of cancer and it's
still more fun than this okay
spoiler alert um season two is on the
way so in the end he obviously didn't
kill himself just like Jeffrey Epstein I
know he's your friend but I don't care
and by the way afterlife which is his
own show that he's plugging there very
cleverly is a really good show and the
funny thing about Gervaise is although
he's a great insult comic he's also
really good at making at mixing
sentimentality and humor so usually with
his shows he's good at that but there
was very little sentimentality last
night which is good at least not from
Ricky Gervais now I didn't watch it past
the monologue but I hear that Gervaise
basically disappeared for the rest of
the four-hour ceremony and showed up you
know a couple of other times one of the
times that he popped back in I think at
the very end he made I thought his best
joke of the night and like the other
jokes it was a joke but also not really
a joke at all right last one last one
come on guys our next presenter starred
in Netflix is bird box a movie where
people survive by acting like they don't
see a thing sort of like working for
Harvey Weinstein
you did it you I didn't you did it
please welcome Sandra Bullock as you can
hear they're the best thing about
cervezas routine was the reaction from
the crowd you could tell that most of
the uproarious sort of laughter was
coming from the back of the room from
the somewhat normal people who showed up
to watch but the front of the room where
the big celebs are sitting you know
there it's awkward silence and with a
few exceptions they showed DiCaprio
laughing a few times which is nice but
most of the other celebrity is grimacing
and just straining to get through it
that's because these people just
absolutely cannot laugh at themselves
they are clinically unable it's it's a
clinical condition they cannot laugh at
themselves they really do believe that
they are our betters and that their
purpose in life is to instruct us and
guide us and show us the wave the way
and when somebody mocks them for doing
that they could only scowl in response
they have no other response you could
practically hear the why I never you
could practically hear that it's an
unspoken why I never coming from the
Hollywood elites in attendance and all
of this of course proves his point you
know if they'd all just laughed
hysterically at their at his jokes and
thus at themselves it would have
undercut what he's saying and it would
have vindicated them a little bit but
instead they responded exactly as he and
the rest of us expect thus vindicating
everything that he was saying about them
and not just the celebrities in the room
also the left-wing media Gervaise was a
hit with the average viewer I think that
much is clear from the social media
response alone in fact Entertainment
Weekly did an online poll asking
everyone what they thought of Gervaise
his performance and the last I checked
it was like 8020 in favor probably not
the response that aw was looking for
meanwhile Lorraine Ali is a TV critic
over at the LA Times and she posted her
review of Gervaise
and and she put it up on Twitter with
this caption it said the Golden Globes
the mood was already sober thanks to an
impeachment threat of war with Iran and
Australian bushfires the last thing
anyone needed was Ricky Gervais is there
telling them they sucked no Lorraine
that's that is exactly what we all
needed to see that is precisely what we
needed reading a bit from her piece now
actually I want to read a good portion
of it because it's just so delicious in
all the ways that she definitely did not
intend so she says forget the escapists
magic of Hollywood nihilism was the name
of the game when host Ricky Gervais is
open the golden globes on Sunday night
with a gloom and doom monologue so
cynical and made the effervescent Tom
Hanks scowl nihilism
she calls it nihilism to attack
Hollywood is nihilistic according to
Lorraine alley you know nihilism is when
you think that nothing matters right
it's when you it's when you think that
life doesn't matter nothing matters
so in Lorraine I leaves mind if you
think that Hollywood doesn't matter then
that's the same thing as thinking life
itself doesn't matter to attack
Hollywood is to attack life itself it's
to attack existence so if you don't like
Hollywood you're a nihilist
according to Lorraine the 58 year old
former are going back to the article now
the 58 year old former Golden Globe
winner and five-time host also
flippantly reminded the packed room that
no one cares about movies anymore Meryl
Streep shook her head Eddie Murphy
refused to smile Quentin Tarantino
looked more disturbed than usual this is
supposed to make us you know turn on
Gervaise we're supposed to go Oh Meryl
Streep shook her head you're telling me
that Meryl Streep didn't like it well
then it must have been terrible Meryl
Streep shook her head the hosts acerbic
wit was nothing new he certainly
offended in the past from the awards
stage and the ads for Sunday's telecast
played upon the idea that anything could
happen including Gervaise being a jerk
his knack for ripping on Hollywood and
offending the glitterati is well-known
among the thin skin in the industry but
at the Beverly Hilton where the
three-hour Plus ceremony took place the
mood was already sober thanks to an
impeachment to the threat of war with
Iran and devastating bush fires in
Australia
backing up for a second yes sober right
that's been the reaction from the left
on impeachment they take it very they
have a very sober minded serious
approach to it it's not like they're
celebrating it it's not like they've
been jumping jumping up and down with
with with shouting with with joy all
right no they're very sober right he
says she says the last thing anyone
needed was for the smirking master of
ceremonies to reprimand them for having
hope or to taunt the room for trying to
infuse their influence to change things
for the better
yes that's it the problem is they have
hope right that's our issue our issue
with with Hollywood is all the hope we
get from it that's what we think when we
turn on the TV and we see a bunch of
drug-addled multimillionaires patting
themselves on the back for five and a
half hours we think to ourselves ugh
these people have too much hope turn
that off there's too much hope that's
what I said when I came home my wife was
watching the gold gloves
turn off that turn off this hope you
listen I look at all that hope all these
people with their hope yes that's
exactly it
Lorraine Ali has her finger on the pulse
you know she really understands she
understands the common man she knows
what makes us tick Gervaise is
disingenuous call for an apolitical
evening was also answered by Russell
Crowe when he won for actor in a limited
series or TV movie for showtimes
Roger Ailes docudrama the loudest room
the actor wrote in a statement make no
mistake the tragedy unfolding in
Australia's climate change based which
the actor wrote a statement read by an
audibly emotional Jennifer Aniston
we need to act based on science move our
global work force to renewable energy
and respect our planet for the unique
and amazing place it is others join the
chorus including Joker winter Joaquin
Phoenix Carol Burnett Award recipient
Ellen DeGeneres and presenter Kate
Blanchet see the drones over LA Times
just our are incapable of understanding
this
nobody cares what Russell Crowe or Kate
Blanchet think about politics or the
state of the world and and nothing they
don't have the right to say they could
say it all they want is just that nobody
cares and that was exactly the point
that your raise was making and then
finally that this is maybe my favorite
part she says as for spectacle
the most notable moment aside from a few
awards upsets was the late arrival of
jay-z and Beyonce the pair stood back
during Kate MacKinnon's moving tribute
to DeGeneres before taking their seats
but they at least provided a
high-voltage moment in a roomful of star
power this says it all ok to the TV
critic in LA the most notable moment the
most electric moment was Beyonce and
jay-z walking into the room just then
simply walking into the room and taking
their seat that's the water cooler
moment in Lorain Isle leaves mind that's
the thing where it worked the next day
you're at the water cooler he said hey
Chuck you watch you catch the Globes
last night man did you see Beyonce
walking into the room Beyonce and jay-z
man unbelievable unforgettable I'll be
telling my grandparents about that one
or my grandchildren sorry maybe I'll
tell my grandparents - that's because
Lorraine Ali worships these people
because she worships people like Beyonce
literally worships them as gods and and
she doesn't understand how anyone else
could see it differently you know for
her to simply lay eyes on Beyonce is is
is a is the defining moment but
that's not how the rest of us you so
Lorraine doesn't get it neither does Vox
predictably in response to jay-z's
Globes monologues they published a piece
Vox did cataloging all the times that
Gervaise has made offensive jokes in the
past so this is a kind of the same thing
that that Media Matters does with us at
the Daily wire all the time where they
come up with these montages and things
of defensive things we've said on our
show but it's all of our best stuff
they're very good at pulling out our
best stuff so Vox didn't say anything
with Gervase pulling out some of his
funniest material and publishing it in
an article thinking that we'll all read
it and shake our heads and disapproval
the way that Meryl Streep would and that
the headline of the article how to tell
a Ricky Gervais joke offend defend
repeat Ricky Gervais says comedians
shouldn't pitch down he's rubbish at
taking his own advice punching down I
mean he's up there taking swipes at the
most powerful people in media and
Hollywood he's insulting Apple and
Amazon and that's punching down
which is absurd but as I said the main
the main ones who who
get it we're in the audience the
celebrities in the audience and nobody
proved that point better than Michelle
Williams who is an actress by the way
she got up to an accept an award and and
proceeded to launch into one of the most
deranged and disturbing speeches I've
seen in a long time a speech where she's
bragging about her own abortions even as
she she'd get up she gets up there
pregnant and is using this opportunity
to brag about having killed one of her
previous children so I want to talk
about that we'll get to in just a moment
but first a word from ring rings mission
is to make neighborhoods safer you know
you might already know about their smart
video doorbells and cameras to protect
millions of people everywhere these
things are are you know you see them
everywhere now so everyone knows about
this but if you if you haven't gotten
ring yet let me tell you about a ring
helps you stay connected to your home
anywhere in the world so if there's a
package delivery or a surprise visitor
you'll get an alert and then you'll be
able to see your see and hear and speak
to them all from your phone no matter
where you are so you can be a thousand
miles away someone comes to your door
you can still talk to them we've been
using ring at our house for months now
and as someone you know myself I tend to
worry a lot about safety and security at
the house and so for me it's been a
godsend it's great that we could see
what's going on at the house even when
we aren't there and also for me I travel
a lot and so my wife is home with the
kids and I appreciate the fact that
because the ring somebody comes to the
door if it's at night or something she
can figure out who's there and talk to
them without actually opening the door
so I think that's great
and then also there's the convenience
aspect of it as well which which I don't
want to understate as a subscriber as a
daily wire subscriber you have a special
offer on a ring welcome kit available
right now and ring.com slash walsh the
kit includes a video doorbell and a
chime Pro which is just what you need to
start building a ring of security around
your house today go to ring.com slash
walsh
that's ring comm slash walsh ring comm
slash walsh alright so at the end of his
monologue Gervaise gave advice to the
people who would follow him on stage
advice that almost all of them disregard
but but here's the advice that he gave
it's pretty good advice pal rolled into
the the TV game with a morning show a
superb drama yes
a superb drama about the importance of
dignity and doing the right thing made
by a company that runs sweatshops in
China so will you say you won't but the
companies you work for I mean
unbelievable Apple Amazon Disney if Isis
started a streaming service you'd call
your agent wouldn't you so if you do win
an award tonight don't use it as a
platform to make a political speech
right you're in no position to lecture
the public about anything you know
nothing about the real world most of you
spend less time in school than Greta
thumb burg so if you win right awards
taint your agent and your god but be
that as it may Michele Williams who won
for something or other was not going to
give up her chance to deliver a homily
and so that's exactly what she did I've
tried my very best to live a life of my
own making not just a series of events
that happened to me but one that I could
stand back and look at and recognize my
handwriting all over sometimes messy and
scrawling sometimes careful and precise
but one that I had carved with my own
hand and I wouldn't have been able to do
this without employing a woman's right
to choose
[Applause]
to choose when to have my children and
with whom when I felt supported and able
to balance our lives knowing as all
mothers know that the scales must and
will tip towards our children now I know
my choices might look different than
yours but thank God or whomever you pray
to that we live in a country founded on
the principle that I am free to live by
my faith and you are free to live by
yours
so women 18 to 118 when it is time to
vote please do so in your own
self-interest it's what men have been
doing for years
okay wow it's just so much to unpack
here first of all the first thing that
jumps out is is she's got the audience
tearfully applauding self-interest I
mean there they are applauding
self-interest right after Gervais spent
seven minutes at the beginning of the
show accusing them of being a bunch of
pretentious high-minded self-interested
phonies and then and then and then
Williams gets up and says yay
self-interest and everybody everybody
applauds you see the woman in the
audience I don't know who that was
crying she's crying tears of joy at the
very thought of self-interest
Michelle Williams says we should be
self-interested and the woman in the
audience oh my god that's so beautiful
yes selfishness I I agree I agree by the
way do you think women especially these
women need you to tell them to vote with
self-interest everybody votes that way
okay
women and men so what is Williams
suggesting is she saying that up until
now women have have as a group been
these selfless martyrs who don't take
their own interests into account when
they go to the voting booth no now
although most people do already vote out
of self-interest so that's the last
thing you need to tell anybody to do and
certainly those people sitting up front
at the Golden Globes are don't need any
guidance or any encouragement to be
self-interested but is that actually
what we should be doing shouldn't we be
voting rather than solely for our own
interest should we should we be voting
for what's best for the country what's
best for our community what's best for
our families what's best for our
children isn't that the more noble
approach here and and and wait a second
sidebar
what is Michelle Williams doing talking
about women as if there's some separate
distinct exclusive group what is she
doing talking about women's bodies
none of that exists anymore Michelle
remember this is keep up with your own
ideology here you're not allowed to say
that stuff anymore that doesn't exist
there is no woman there is no man that
distinction is meaningless
that's your worldview it's not mine
that's yours that's what you think now
if we could put that to the side which
we can't but if we could then we get to
the bit about abortion and what again
what an incredible illustration and
vindication of Gervaise point you've got
this roomful of wealthy narcissists
wearing outfits that cost more than my
car applauding the murder of children
applauding self-interest and child
murder you've got a multi-millionaire
celebrity winning an award for doing a
good job of pretending to be somebody
else bragging about the time she killed
her child and her millionaire friends
applauding him now actually let's go
back I want to go back and isolate that
part let's go back and listen just to
the part about abortion because there's
a few things worth noting as women and
as girls things can happen to our bodies
that are not our choice I've tried my
very best to live a life of my own
making not just a series of events that
happened to me but one that I could
stand back and look at and recognize my
handwriting all over sometimes messy and
scrawling sometimes careful and precise
but one that I had carved with my own
hand and I wouldn't have been able to do
this without employing a woman's right
to choose
to choose when to have my children and
with whom when I felt supported and able
to balance our lives knowing as all
mothers know that the scales must and
will tip towards our children okay again
this woman's body stuff what is a
woman's body what is that that that
that's not a thing that exists anymore
according to Michelle's own worldview so
I just okay fine well just well we'll
try to put that to the side she says
that things can happen to a woman's body
that they don't choose she says abortion
enables her to decide when to have kids
and with whom now unless we're talking
about rape this is all nonsense except
in cases of rape which accounts for less
than 1% of all abortions so in the 99%
of cases when a woman gets pregnant she
did absolutely choose it even if she
didn't want to get pregnant she still
chose to do the thing that has billions
of times in the past resulted in the
conception of a new human life that was
her choice and with whom well she chose
that too she chose to have sex with a
male member of the species they they
chose to participate in the reproductive
act that's a choice they made you get
rid of abortion you do not at all
impinge on choice even slightly you do
not interfere with a woman's ability to
choose who she has sex with or to choose
whether or not to have sex in the first
place also I want you to note something
else it's kind of subtle so maybe you
might have missed this she says that
abortion allows her to choose when to
have my children and with whom
you notice that notice the phrasing she
says you know I could choose when to
have my children and with whom so the
phrasing there is interesting when to
have my children my children so Williams
has a daughter right now and that's I
don't know how old you had a child um
and she's also currently pregnant so she
was extolling the virtues of child
murder while she was pregnant which is
sick but the way she phrases it makes it
sound like you know my children the two
that I have were gonna come earlier but
it wasn't the right time so instead I
had them later I didn't want to have my
children earlier so I had the abortion
and then I had my children later so this
makes it sound like you can have an
abortion and then postponed Parenthood
for a time and then become a parent
later as if the child that's been
conceived you can abort that child and
then have that same child later this is
the this is the delusion that abortion
clinics sell to women but of course it's
not true it is a delusion when you
conceive a child you have a child
if you kill that child they aren't going
to be rican sieved and then born some
other time in the in the in the
undetermined future they they're dead
and you're still a parent you haven't
put off parenthood so when you have an
abortion
you're not putting off that child and
you're not putting off parenthood that's
still your child and you're still a
parent it's just that now you're the
parent of a dead child and that child
will stay dead forever and when you do
have a child in the future that's not
gonna be the child that you aborted that
child is dead so now the child that you
do have is going to have a dead sister
or a dead brother that's the reality of
abortion it doesn't allow you to choose
when to have kids that choice you know
that by the time the abortion occurs
that's irrelevant
the choice of wind to have kids is is
something that needs to happen before
conception
okay if you put off conception then you
have put off having kids but when you
have the abortion you already had the
kid
just that now the child is dead
and that's you know the the blunt way of
putting it but there's no other way to
put it
so Michelle Williams you know according
to her she says she had at least one
abortion she alludes to there so she
Michelle Williams has three children two
alive and one dead all right
there's more to discuss but first a word
from Rock Auto you know chain stores
have different price tiers for
professional mechanics and
do-it-yourselfers the great thing with
Rock Auto is that their prices are the
same for everybody and they're also
reliably low for everybody so you'll
have to worry about they're gonna try to
you know get more out of you because
you're not a professional Rock Auto
always offers the lowest prices possible
to everybody rather than changing their
prices according to what the market will
bear or according to what they think
they can get you to pay rockauto.com is
a family business you know it's it's
what I like about it it's online but
it's also family-run serving Auto Parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com the shop shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules brake parts lamps
tail lamps motor oil new carpet whatever
whatever you need whether it's for your
classic or your daily driver getting
everything you need just takes a few
easy clicks delivered directly to your
door the rockauto.com catalog is unique
very easy to navigate and you could
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and you could choose the
brand and specifications the prices you
prefer don't have to be a car expert to
navigate this thing and find what you
need
amazing selection reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com go to Rock Auto calm right
now see all the parts available for your
car truck Rock auto calm and remember to
write Walsh in there how did you hear
about us box so that they know that we
sent you all right before we answer a
few emails here one other thing you know
the the fastest-growing genre in US
fiction is the genre where a person
makes up a fake story about something
bad that happened to them and of course
a convention of this genre is that the
person doing the bad thing the villain
in the story is always a trump supporter
right and though although it's not
always specified how exactly we know
that the villain is a trump supporter we
just know it
intuitively so we've got our latest
entry into this genre it's a genre that
for shorthand we could call this genre
Smollett so our latest Smollett is from
a woman named Wendy Trung and she had a
tale to tell
and she told it on Twitter yesterday
this is what she said she said my son
and I were in Costco Rhys sorry my son
and I were in Costco quietly discussing
his deployment and a woman walked up to
us and said what are you crying about
you won't you won't have any more kids
to bother you when he dies and you'll
have his life-insurance money my son had
to pull my hands from her neck f these
maggots maggots as an Maga TS the term
for for the reference to Trump
supporters okay so she claims that she
was at Costco just talking to her son
binding her business and she starts I
guess crying about the fact that he's
gonna deploy and this woman out of
nowhere comes in and says what are you
crying about he's not gonna bother you
anymore when he's dead and then you'll
get his life-insurance money I I listen
you know lots of things haven't happened
in this world but very few things
haven't happened as emphatically as this
didn't happen I mean this didn't even
come close to happening I doubt that she
was even in a Costco this is not even in
the vicinity of something that could
even possibly have happened now you have
to give her points for being bold though
because she just is not concerned with
believability at all sheep she has no
concern for that she's tossing that to
the wind also doesn't explain by they're
explaining how she knows that the woman
is a trump supporter maybe she screamed
this is Magga country afterwards she
doesn't she doesn't explain but this is
the claim that she makes this is this
this this story in this story this this
woman this Trump supporter this
fictional Trump's work this is the least
believable villain since like I don't
know
the guy from Power Rangers Lord Zedd
this is it would be more believable to
me if she said that the villain from
Power Rangers showed up and drop-kicked
her I would be more likely to believe
that than this but you you notice
something about these fake stories and
this is how you always know that they're
fake these fake stories that left this
make up to to smear Trump supporters you
notice that these people these leftist
just have taken no time and exerted no
energy in trying to actually understand
the other side they don't see the other
side of the political divide they don't
see them as people
they're caricatures they're cartoons
because this this fictional Trump
supporter that she made up in her fake
story this is that is just not how
people operate at all
there's nothing believable about that
that is not a human being that's a
cartoon and the fact that this is what's
significant about it it's that - Wendy
Trung you know she thinks that's
believable because that's how she sees
Trump supporters she sees them as the
kind of people who would go to you at
Costco and and tell you that it's okay
if your son dies because you'll get his
life insurance money meanwhile the son
is standing right there that that's how
she sees Trump supporters which which
tells you that either she has never come
out of her bubble to actually interact
with Trump supporters or when she does
she's not paying attention at all
to who they actually are and how they
operate because if she did she would see
that these are normal people who she
disagrees with but they're normal people
they're not cartoon villains as it turns
out all right
so that's maybe a lesson if if
to take the time to understand the other
side just as a matter of being in you
know just for the sake of yourself being
a decent person just for the sake of
empathy then maybe at least take that
time so that you can make makeup more
believable stories when you try to smear
them in the future
think of it as as research it's research
for the part that you're trying to play
in the future you want to play the part
of the victim of an evil Trump supporter
well then you really got to take the
time do the research figure out what
make what makes these people tick all
right you know 2020 is gonna be a
bottomless pit of savagery as we watch
Democrats attempt to rip apart the
fabric of our political system in order
to get rid of Trump the best way to stay
informed and stay on top of all of it
god help us is to become a daily water
member and get comprehensive news and
opinion from us on demand and today is
the last day the very last day to get
20% off all memberships that's 20% off
all memberships when using promo code DW
2020 members get our our articles add
free access to all of our live
broadcasts and show library the full
three hours of the ben shapiro show
every day
select bonus content access to the
mailbag everything you could want what
else we have to give you people plus our
new all-access tear gets you live online
Q&A discussions with me ben shapiro
andrew Clavin michael knowles plus our
sites other contributors and writers and
special guests so if you have a question
you can get an answer again that's promo
code DW 2024 20% off all memberships
today only trust me you don't want to
miss this all right let's go to emails
Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com this one is from
Dannette says warm greetings to you from
sunny Chicago first off I love your show
and I actively watch all of the daily
wires content via the new app and even
though I've been a subscriber for a
month now with this this I didn't do
this on purpose this actually works
pretty nicely from the from what I was
just talking about the promo there so
here we have a someone who's who uses
the new app even though I've been a
subscriber for
month now and have yet to receive the
legendary tumbler a wink-wink
nudge-nudge I'm not bitter about it well
I'll make sure you get that Dannette
I'll look into that
attached is a picture of my family's
favorite dinner what you what you have
the privilege of gazing upon is a
bacon-wrapped pork tenderloin on a bed
of various vegetables salted with Toni's
Creole seasoning or as I like to call it
pig in a pig blanket it is broiled and
served with my homemade smoked cheddar
gravy we are primarily a keto household
so don't worry this decadence will not
kill us I hope that my bacon is a keto
or keto by the way which one is it I'm
going with keto I hope that my bacon
cooking method meets your approval as
you are particular about your bacon ok
so then that has given us a picture of
her bacon her bacon dish let's take a
look at this picture that you sent in
that here it is now I'm gonna leave that
up on the screen for a minute because we
really need to get into this the net you
want me to review your bacon I will do
it but you can't get offended now you
remember you asked for this now the
management training course that I took
for my assistant manager job at Domino's
when I was 19
told me that you should always couch
criticism with positive feedback as well
so on a positive note
I like the idea behind your dish I like
your energy I like your hustle I like
your commitment to pork I like the
cheddar gravy idea all that is good very
commendable unfortunately the execution
is a disaster on the level of the
Hindenburg now this is supposed to be
the finished product correct what we're
looking at here so you've already cooked
it
if you've already cooked this
then why is there raw bacon draped over
the pork is the pork tenderloin raw too
is that just a live Pig hanging out
under there I mean look at this bacon
look at this bacon there is precisely
one piece of bacon that is properly
cooked on this entire dish and you could
spot it yourself it's right there you
see the horizontal strips of bacon at
the bottom of the strength screen the
one in the middle right there
that is the only properly cooked piece
of bacon
and how do you know that it's properly
cooked will you notice the coloring you
notice the charred edges you notice the
texture it's got all of the the
hallmarks of a properly well-cooked
piece of bacon so well done you did one
nicely cooked piece beggin the problem
is there's like 20 pieces of bacon on
that thing and I would never say that
it's a problem that 20 pieces of bacon
it's only a problem when you don't cook
the other 19 now really having that one
well-cooked piece of bacon only makes
the rest of it worse because then you
get the you know now we can compare it
so compare that to the vertical slice
all the way to the far left of the of
the screen or no the far right
depending on which way you're looking at
this now notice it's it's sickly pale
white appearance it looks like it has
the stomach flu pale sweaty soggy just
lying there a limp and you serve that to
your family are you trying to kill them
my god Dannette this is if my wife
served that to me we'd be in marriage
counseling that's how bad it is
now the bacon does get progressively
better as you go down the Tenderloin but
even the even the best cooked piece of
bacon is not cooked very well at all so
let me ask you this tonight when you
make meatballs do you just you know take
the ground beef and grab a chunk of raw
ground beef and throw it on the table
throw it in your husband's face
here's your meatball is that what you do
because that's the equivalent of what
you've done here I can't look at this
anymore
I am I am shocked and appalled I have to
assume that this is some sort of
practical joke
but thank you for being a subscriber and
thank you for for listening as well
appreciate your support let's go to
Victor says hi Matt I agree with
everything you say about gender men are
men and women are women but I've always
struggled with your insistence that we
shouldn't use people's preferred
pronouns you say that calling a man ashy
or vice versa is bad grammar and
violates the rules of language but
grammar is a social convention and
changes with the time anyway I think
your argument is weak I think your
argument is weak here yes the left is
trying to change the rules of language
but the rules of language always change
so what's the big deal well I think you
have my argument wrong Victor my problem
with calling a man a she is not that it
violates the rules of grammar something
that's ungrammatical it's that it's
incomprehensible and also it's false so
you know if I say that we should call
elephants elephants and not horses I'm
not making a point about grammar it's
not bad grammar to call an elephant a
horse that's not you wouldn't call that
bad grammar that's just a lie or a
mistake or a you know a mark of
confusion and if we were to codify this
new rule or policy where elephants can
be called elephants or horses and horses
can be horses or elephants then we have
made language unintelligible not just
ungrammatical we've made it
unintelligible nobody has any idea what
anyone's talking about now it's true
it's true that we don't have to call
elephants elephants we could call them
anything we want and every language has
its own its own word for elephant right
so that's not the point the actual word
that we use for elephant the word
elephant itself is basically arbitrary
we could use any word
you think about a word is a symbol now
every word is a symbol and because it
stands for something and when you're
communicating you are to somebody else
you are putting into their head a whole
string of symbols where each thing that
you say stands for something in the real
world or something in your mind that
you're trying to convey and and so
that's what it is so you could use any
symbol to stand for elephant we use the
word elephant fine but the point is you
need to have a different symbol for
elephant than you do for horse it
doesn't matter what it is whatever the
word is whatever the sound is whatever
the symbol is it doesn't matter it could
be literally any word it just has to be
a distinct word it has to not be the
same word that you use for horse or else
again language fails to do the thing
that language is supposed to do which is
convey meaning that's the point when I'm
speaking to you I am trying to
communicate meaning and I want you to
understand what I'm saying
now this point you make about grammar
being an arbitrary convention and so it
doesn't doesn't make any sense to insist
on maintaining a convention and
resisting the change of a convention
that to me I understand what you're
saying I actually agree with what you're
saying I just think that you're applying
it to the wrong thing so that to me
applies to like the the whole thing
about not ending a sentence with a
preposition for instance grammar nazis
who correct you when you say he knows
what i'm talking about rather than he
knows about what i'm talking or there's
the person i wanted to talk to rather
than there's the person to whom I wanted
to talk or she's the girl I went to prom
with rather than she's the girl with
whom I went to prom or that's someone I
look up to rather than that someone up
to whom I look etcetera now here's an
example of an entirely arbitrary
grammatical convention and something
that is subject to change and that has
no real objective reason to exist in
truth it doesn't matter
if you end a sentence with a preposition
there's no reason why that should be
wrong we just say that it is but it
doesn't have to be
and so when you say you know if you say
something like that's the person I went
to prom with you're not conveying an
untruth unless provided you actually did
go to prom with that person and you
aren't saying anything unintelligible
everybody knows what you mean and that's
why grammar nazis are so annoying is
because when you say that's the person I
want to prom with and the grammar nazi
says no it's with whom you went to prom
okay you know what I mean you understand
what I'm saying don't you what's the
point of the correction this is this is
a successful human communication I told
you that's the person I was the problem
you understand what that means there's
no reason to correct me
in fact often the 'vote the the attempt
to avoid the dangling preposition makes
the sentence less comprehensible instead
of more like that's the person up to
whom I look technically grammatically
correct but also it's clunky and weird
and it takes you a second to even
understand what I'm talking about it
makes better so it makes more sense and
it's better to just say that's the
person I look up to
the whole point of grammatical
convention is to help language be
comprehensible
if a convention cuts against that goal
it's probably time to change it you know
that's for me as a as a writer I don't
honestly I'm not overly worried about
all the technical rules of grammar I'm
worried about just getting my point
across that's all I want to do I want
you to understand what I'm saying and so
yeah well and a sentence in the
preposition for me and I and I think
this is what most people do this is what
most people do it's it's kind of a
feeling it's you you you in that we all
have this with language we have a feel
for it
and so you look at a sentence and you
might not be able to break it down
grammatically and identify all the parts
of speech and everything but you look at
a sentence and you sort of know if it
feels right or not does it look like the
right kind of sentence or not and there
could be times when a technically
grammatically correct sentence feels
wrong I mean I do this sometimes when
I'm writing where I put a sentence down
on the on the paper when out on the
paper but on the screen and I look at it
and it's grammatically correct but it
just feels wrong it looks weird it's
clunky it's kind of it throws off the
rhythm and so I'll correct it to a to a
grammatically incorrect version of it
just because it looks better and I think
it does a better job of getting my point
across you know the preposition thing
that's I think that goes back to the
18th century it was really just a guy in
the 18th century came up with this rule
that you can't end a sentence in a
preposition he just came up with it and
ever since then and everyone says okay
well I guess we won't do that anymore
but to to to insist that 21st century
English speakers adhere to 18th century
grammatical convention is silly and
pointless why not insist on 16th century
grammatical convention why not insist
that we use words like vine and vow and
sayeth obviously if somebody spoke that
way today we would look at them like
they're crazy or
like they're joking around even though
it's grammatically correct technically I
mean technically a word like sayeth or
thine it's probably technically better
grammar than what we say today instead
but who cares here's the other thing
about changes in grammatical convention
inauthentic change happens on its own
organically so it's not like somebody
decided in 1983 that now we're gonna
start saying went to prom with rather
than with whom I went to prom it just
shifted the language evolved as
languages always do and everywhere do
and will always do in the future
languages always change always evolve
its net and that fact is never going to
change with this pronoun stuff on the
other hand it's very different okay so
when you've got language naturally
evolving I think that's basically fine
as long as meaning is maintained now
what you see online these days of people
replacing written language altogether
with emojis and stuff where now we're at
the point where people can't even
verbally or with writing communicate
their emotions without putting a smiley
face down now we're back to using
hieroglyphics I'm not a fan of that
because that's a devolution that's a
degrading of language where language
becomes less precise it's it's less able
to you know let's it's not as rich
anymore you're not able to communicate
your your emotions and and and your
thoughts as well so that I think is a
problem but all of that is different
from the pronoun stuff and I'll tell you
why because with the pronoun stuff we
have a small group a small politically
motivated group trying to impose a
change they're not observing a change
they're not defending a change that's
already happened they're insisting on
the change
okay and they're not doing like what I'm
doing with prep with the preposition
thing with prepositions I'm saying this
change has already happened the
convention is already shifted it's fine
there's really no problem with it so who
cares
with the pronouns that's totally
different
we motivate a group who are in sang this
must chant it hasn't changed
people still say he/she all that the
small politically motivated group is
saying no no we must change this and not
because they want to make language more
intelligible rather they want to make it
less intelligible their stated goal is
to prevent the hearer from fully
comprehending what the speaker is saying
so that when a pronoun is used they
don't want the hearer to really know
whether it's referring to a biological
male or female they're trying to cut
there they're trying to obscure
rather than elucidate or illuminate and
so that's that's the difference I mean
you didn't think we were going to end
with a 20 minute spiel on grammar but
here we are
that just happened folks we can't go
back now and I think we'll leave it
there thanks everybody for watching
thanks for listening hope you get some
good sleep tonight I know that I will
not Godspeed the Matt Walsh show is
produced by Sean Hampton executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan Hey supervising producer Mathis
Glover supervising producer Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens editor Donovan Fowler audio
mixer Robin Fenderson the Matt Walsh
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 if you prefer
facts over feelings aren't offended by
the brutal truth and you can still laugh
at the insanity filling our national
news cycle well tune in to the ben
shapiro show we'll get a whole lot of
that and much more see you there